the really wild thing about the end
training is that it like it learns to
read like you can read science but we
never taught it to
read
so yeah we never taught it what we never
taught it what a car was or what a
person was or a B
cyclist uh it
learned what what all those things are
what all the objects are on the
road uh from video just from watching
videos just like humans I mean humans
are photons in control controls out like
the vast majority of information
reaching our brain is from our eyes um
and you say well what's the output the
output is our motor signals to
our sort of fingers and mouth in order
to
communicate
um protons in controls out the same is
true of the car
but by looking at the sequence of images
it's you've agreed with ilas discover
recently where he talked about llm
forming a world model and basically
language is a projection of that world
model onto the sequence of yeah letters
and and you saying it finds order in in
in these things uh it
finds correlative
clusters in so doing it's like
understanding something deep about the
world yeah which is
like it's beautiful that's how our brain
works yeah but it's it's beautiful in
controls out neur nuts are able to
understand that deep meaning in the
world and so the question is how far can
to go and it does seem everybody's
excited about llms so in the space of
self-supervised learning in the space of
text yeah um it it seems like there's a
deep similarity between that and what
Tesla autopal is doing is it to you
basically the same
but no
converging I wonder who gets there
faster understand having a deep
understanding of the
world or they just will naturally
converge they're both headed towards
AGI um the tail approach is much more
computer efficient it had to be cuz we
were constrained on
this this you know we only have 100
Watts
um and in8
computer 144 trillion operations per
second which sounds like a lot but is
kind of small potatoes these
days at in8 but it's understanding the
world at
in8 it's only 256
values but there the path to AGI might
have much more significant imp impact
because it's
understanding it'll it'll faster
understand the real world than will llms
and there for be able to integrate with
with the real humans in the real world
faster they're both um going to un
understand the world but I think Tesla's
approach is fundamentally more computer
efficient it had to be there was no
choice like our brain is very computer
efficient very energy efficient so think
of like what what is our brain able to
do um you know there's only about 10
watts of higher brain function not
counting stuff that's just used to
control our body um the thinking part of
our brain is less than 10 watts um and
that 10 those 10 watts can still produce
a much better novel than a 10 megawatt
GPU cluster so there's a six order of
magnitude difference
there um I mean the the AI thus far
gotten to where it is via Brute Force
just throwing massive amounts of compute
and and massive amounts of power at it
so this is not where where it will end
up um you know in general with any given
technology you first try to make it work
and then you make it
efficient so I think we'll find over
time that these models
get smaller are able to do
produce a sensible output with far
less compute far less
power um Tesla is arguably ahead of the
game on that front because um it has
we've just been forced
to try to understand the world with 100
watts of
compute um and there are a bunch of sort
of fundamental functions that we kind of
forgot to include so we have to run them
a bunch of things in emulation
um we fixed fixed a bunch of those with
hard rare 4 and then hard rare 5 will be
even better
um but it does appear at this point uh
that the car will be able to drive
better than a human even with Hardware 3
and 100 wats of
power and
really if we really optimize it could be
probably less than 50
wats